buonasera siamo a metà degli anni 90 si
presentano gianni diventiamo amici lui
di professione fa il professore di
inglese ha una passione la musica e le
chitarre
io faccio l'architetto e mi occupo anche
di design in realtà e mi piace anche
muovere le mani
gianni mi lancia un tema costruire una
chitarra di metallo che già la cosa non
la capivo molto bene ma lui la chiamava
una chitarra meticcia io devo dire che
resisteva un po a questa idea un po
anche per il timore rispetto allo
strumento lo strumento musicale è una
cosa molto difficile da approcciare poi
l'idea di costruire di ridisegnare un
altra forma di chitarra ce n'erano tante
gianni insiste mi fa vedere due immagini
di due chitarre una una chitarra
acustica degli anni 30 una dobro o
national è una chitarra al corpo di
metallo di ferro e il manico di legno e
il primo tentativo di dare più suona una
chitarra infatti dentro a dei coni che
amplificano il sono una cosa meccanica
poi abbiamo la telecaster che è la prima
chitarra che leo fender costruisce a
metà degli anni negli anni 40 è un'icona
ormai quindi mi lascio convincere
cominciò a lavorare a pensare
prendo le lamiere lo prima l'ottone poi
l'acciaio le lamiere e le saldature ma
quando arrivò all'attacco del manico col
corpo che è un punto strategico dello
strumento la soluzione non mi soddisfa
un giorno guardando una fresa controllo
numerico che stava lavorando un pezzo di
plexiglas
io in un infezione dico ma potrei usare
questa tecnologia in più
pensavo
non all acciaio ma l'alluminio che è un
metallo meno metallo degli altri mi
sembrava così in maniera molto naif
molto più vicino al legno e questa
l'idea quindi prendere un blocco di
alluminio e scavarlo quindi io potevo
ottenere tutte diciamo le cose che mi
servivano e soprattutto questo attacco
del corpo e il manico però ritorna
l'officina era il tra scopro che il
signore nell'officina mi fa un
preventivo altissimo eravamo negli anni
90 quindi due milioni di lire mi chiede
che in realtà era era una cosa troppo
costosa per per la chitarra di gianni
stavamo giocando quindi passano dei mesi
il progetto si stoppa al rientro delle
vacanze la mia socia cc annuncia che si
sposa e io scopro con offre che mauro
che il terzo elemento che scatena poi
l'alchimia in realtà lui e dirige un
reparto l'aermacchi lui con l'alluminio
ci fa volare gli aeroplani e è un attimo
coinvolgerlo
da lì inizia tutta una serie di lavoro
che dura un annetto recuperare i disegni
originali della fender ridisegnarlo
passare dal cad al cam e alla fine
riusciamo e nasce la prima noi la
chiamiamo l'ammiraglia è già lì c'è un
primo una prima cosa molto interessante
e molto una piccola innovazione grande
non lo so il pick up che è una delle
famiglie di microfoni che stanno sulle
chitarre elettriche quello originale il
primo pick up single coil fare un fa
ronzio quando viene attaccato
l'amplificatore nel nostro caso invece
no questo dire un colpo di fortuna di
fatto
ma comunque la chitarra e silenziosa
muta quindi è un'innovazione abbastanza
come dire stupefacente lo stesso liutaio
era stupefatto ma comunque la chitarra
subito viene definita come una chitarra
che non sostengo al pianoforte piuttosto
che un attacco molto preciso un suono
cristallino e esso è anche una dinamica
e la dinamica e la capacità dello
strumento di percepire il musicista che
una sensibilità
se vogliamo cominciamo a frequentare le
fiere chiaramente il mondo del mondo dei
chitarristi di fatto subito abbiamo come
dire una strana sensazione
i chitarristi vedono un corpo di
alluminio non è di legno sulla paletta
non c'è un logo rassicurante e quindi
c'è come dire una sorta di diffidenza
poi frequentiamo i blog dove si discute
di chitarre e e questo dopo un paio
d'anni di perché avesse serviva per
imparare poi questo mondo e all'interno
di questi blog
la cosa strana che succedeva che le
domande e le risposte erano sempre le
stesse ma il tempo passava e e non è che
erano le stesse persone ma le persone
cambiavano quindi dal mio punto di vista
era come dire un mondo morto quindi a
quel punto si capiva il perché c'era una
sorta di diffidenza però non è che
questo noi comunque avevamo dei
musicisti d'eccellenza che ci seguivano
che suonavano la nostra chitarra quindi
decidiamo di entrare in una sorta di
clandestinità ci ritiriamo nella nostra
cantina frequentiamo intorno alla
chitarra si forma una sorta di comunità
di persone che ci credono che sono
interessate e quindi decidiamo sulla
chitarra è buona si fa la strada da sola
e questa diciamo questa convergenza poi
è interessante perché non è fatta
proveniente per la nostra attitudine non
è fatta solo dei chitarristi mai fatta
anche di artisti vito acconci
si disegna una chitarra che non è ancora
nata piuttosto che un giovane designer
che si presenta con un idea e disegna la
paraffina che è la seconda linea della
noah per cui pronti a recepire qualsiasi
qualche indicazione qualsiasi sogno
qualsiasi idea e costruiamo il primo
basso versato urbino il per il bassista
di jovanotti il quale si fa fare proprio
il primo basso da noi oppure un
ragazzino che con 21 anni si presenta e
dice io ho provato a fare una nova è
carinissimo e quello viene coinvolto
subito ed è un po ormai un partner
assolutamente stabile
dobbiamo venderle quindi siamo
clandestini e non ci rimane solo che il
passaparola
poi sono gli anni in cui nasce il virus
marketing che non capivano bene cosa
fosse in realtà il passaparola e poi
succede una cosa molto molto
interessante la definiamo il virus del
dono ma perchè perchè lo so saturnino
che un bassista regala uno dei nostri
bassi a sting e chiaro che sul musicista
regala un altro musicista vuol dire che
siamo sulla strada buona
piuttosto che un artigiano un artigiano
di napoli amico di lou reed lui regala
una delle nostre chitarre
la cosa interessante è che la regala e
riceviamo una mail di lou reed quale
questa ve la voglio dire la prima frase
dice questa è una chitarra per scrivere
non personale che nel caso di lou reed
credo che sia e questo ci ci elettrizza
chiaramente poi si presentano in news
comprano un basso jovanotti e saturnino
regalano un basso a ben harper il quale
si porta di una chitarra che poi viene
presa da di age e quindi ci sono trovati
catapultati diciamo in un mondo che non
ci aspettavamo questa è un po
come dire la storia cosa stiamo facendo
adesso stiamo lavorando sulla chitarra
aumentata che è un anno che ci stiamo
lavorando
a bordo dello strumento c'è in realtà un
computer che elabora in tempo reale il
suono che il musicista fa non c'è niente
di campionato non anzi non sostituisce
neanche le pedaliere che sono quegli
oggetti che chitarristi hanno davanti
e la speranza del lavoro che stiamo
facendo è è anche una sorta di alfabeto
del gesto perché gli effetti verranno
come direzionati da dei gesti
questo è un lavoro abbastanza
velleitario ma anche al quale però ci
crediamo molto
vi ringrazio marco colombo vi farà
sentire la nona
f